Lighthouse mentoring which is a unique
and vital initiative within the Sapiens
Institute mentors those struggling with
doubts empowers new Muslims guides those
who have left the dean and provides
support to imams teachers parents and
dua to make an impact in the da this
Ramadan we're taking lighthouse
mentoring to the next level as its own
organization we've already mentored
thousands achieving an incredible 90%
success rate in helping people recon
connect with Islam and make a lasting
impact in their communities. But we
can't stop there. There are many people
all around the world that need our help.
We need
1,500 lightkeepers, supporters, and
donors who will commit just £10 a month
to ensure this life-changing work
continues. Be the first to take
Lighthouse to the next level. Be a
lightkeeper this Ramadan. How
are you guys? I'm with Rono here in
Estonia. A place that you wouldn't
expect us to go toh, but a fantastic
place, a fertile grounds for da. Would
you say so?
We done a bit of a da training yesterday
at night time actually. And uh you know
what? We're going to Lapia next.
Yesterday was really dark outside and
now it's almost sunny. How do you like
the view here? It's not bad. It's really
It's really nice. Well, this place we
were just saying is it's got a bit like
Scandinavian vibes, but it's also got
like Soviet vibes. We're here in the old
city. You can see he's a big man. Have
you got Have you got bigger Have you got
bigger one? Show us. This is not bad.
What do you What do you think of this?
It's fine. It's fine.
This is how you Is that right? Yes. You
ever seen like a a hat and a thing and a
scarf? Two in one. Yeah. Well, I'm a
hijab in it. So, you need to hijab as
well. So, now we're approaching the the
best nicest area in the old town, the
main square. All of these buildings
around here are very uh historic. This
here is the the oldest continuously
working pharmacy in Europe. It was
established at year 1422.
Now I know how
well. This is an Orthodox church. If I'm
not mistaken, the most of the Christians
nowadays in Estonia, they are the
Orthodox. So, this concludes our little
uh walk around the Estonian or Italian
old town. So, alhamdulillah, we're ready
to set out uh towards Latvia. Uh
although the plan was first to go with
small two small cars, but in order to
benefit and share the brotherhood uh in
one space, we decided to get the van.
So, we just get all the stuff out of the
other cars and uh go to the van
inshallah. I'm here with my brother
Fazan. Oh, sorry about that.
I'm here with my brother Than. We're
going from
uh Estonia to Latvia, from Talin, the
the capital of Estonia, Tia, the capital
of Latvia. And I'm sure many of the
viewers didn't even know that these were
the capitals. And many of the viewers
wouldn't have even heard of these
countries, bro. That's how bad it is.
And thing is, these are the countries in
Europe with the least Muslim population.
Yes. So, Assam, we're here in central
Latia. What do you think of this place?
Sunny, people are friendly. Let's take a
look around.
I'm not really good with the camera as
you guys can see. Yeah. Go on. You know,
you definitely have the right angle.
Yeah. No, Allah has blessed us with a
lovely day. It's nice and sunny. Yeah.
Uh people over here they're a lot
friendlier than in Estonia. I don't
know. Oh, it's very controversial
opinion already. Hey, the controversial
the lowest number of Muslims in Europe.
uh to get them enthused and energized
about doing
da to give them the tools to give them
the intellectual arguments to give them
the confidence to go out to their
communities and give da
uh so after tonight's training we uh
went had a nice meal. It's almost 3:00
a.m. now and we're finally reaching the
hotel. So, now we're in Lafia, the
second of the Baltic states that we're
visiting. Beautiful hotel here. We spent
one night and now we're going straight
to Lithuania. It's sunny. It's cold but
sunny. It's beautiful and it's a
different flavor to us.
Makes a huge difference to the weather
cuz it's like dark and cold and there's
no sun. It's actually not even that cold
today. Yeah. It's not as depressing
either, huh? Yeah, it's always dark. Why
is it sunny in these in these areas?
It's barely. Sometimes it is, but those
these days are This is the most This is
really good. The last couple of days we
were freezing. Yeah, exactly.
Beautiful. What is this?
Even the dogs here are different.
The dogs looking nice. Yeah. So, we're
here in central Latia and this is the
freedom monument, so-called freedom
monument. Uh, as you can see in the top
here, there's three stars that are
presented and these represent I think
the three Baltic countries that had, you
know, gotten independence from the
Soviet Union. But what I found
interesting is the guards here. You got
two guards who are kind of performing
the same function as you would see
outside of Buckingham Palace. I think in
Western Europe we think that these um
traditions and conventions are very
particular to British culture. Actually
these guys have very similar things and
they're moving around as well actually
doing the kind of march that is also
done outside of Blackingham Valley. Very
interesting. And um I just saw somebody
come and adjust one of the hats of the
guards cuz they could maybe touch it
themselves. Very interesting
conventions.
[Music]
Look at that. Beautiful. I don't know if
you guys can see that, but these birds
are just beautifully migration birds
migrating from the south to the north.
So, we are just arriving in the uh
Islamic center in Dillius. So, we're in
Lithuania. We're doing a bit of da
training. Okay. And uh as you can see
the people here, they're practicing some
of
the some of the arguments that we're
putting forward. And the idea really is
because as I mentioned, Lithuania is one
of the countries with the least amount
of Muslims uh in Europe. And we're
trying to embolden and strengthen and
give confidence and intellectual
argumentation to the Muslim community
here. And then after that we're going to
give them links to uh the lighthouse
mentoring service if anyone is
particularly facing like doubts new
Muslims for Muslims who are newly
practicing etc. that they can link
themselves with the lighthouse mentoring
will give them resources and we'll be in
constant communication with them to see
that they're you know developing in the
good in the good way that they should
be. But this is I think a neglected
aspect of the daer cuz especially when
people get famous Yeah. like myself,
right? It gets tempting to just go to
countries with a lot of people in the
audience, you know, just to for whatever
reason, but really the real work with
more impact is done in countries like
this where there's less people, okay?
But it's a focus group and they're all
working in a manner that would we can
actually impart real um knowledge to
them in a in a meaningful kind of
pedagogical way. So, I'm hoping that
this bears fruits. I think it really
will because there's it's fertile ground
here for DA in countries. Lithuania, I
think, has got a bit more of an
established Muslim community. Um, but
yeah, we'll see how it goes. I'll keep
you guys updated.
I'm from Alexandria. Oh,
yeah. But barely lived there mostly.
Which part of Alexandria? Do you know?
Um, you know, shoots. This is our
Islamic center in Vus, Lithuania. This
Islamic Center is divided into groups.
At the moment, they're actually opening
each other. Anyone who's free and can
come. So, it's
a nice place, cozy place to spend their
time. They can work, they can come and
pray. for example, but uh what is good
that they uh the kids are attached to
the Islamic center and when there's they
go and pray
and so like this you know basically
Sunday is the day for kids here playing
jumping lessons and then in the break
they
[Music]
play Muhammad is the tallest I'm the
tallest
In some countries if you make it if you
pour it full it's
disrespect. If you pour a little bit
this is good because otherwise you would
show that you want the guest to leave if
you make it. So that's and also this is
one thing and another wisdom is that if
you pour little and you make little it's
quickly getting cold and you can drink.
So it's uh you know east is very
dangerous.
Got to be careful on this. We're in the
graveyard here.
And Subhan Allah. This is a reminder for
us. These are the evidence that we had a
lot of Muslims because of the
graveyards. Yeah, there are many of them
all over the territory of Lithuania. You
can go. So, this is one of the oldest
mosques here in Lithuania.
So, now inshallah, we'll be entering
this
masjid. We also have some space
upstairs. There's a stairs leading up
from there. There's a classic well we
used to have like grandmother's place as
well as well. Is it still functional?
Like can you get the water and stuff
from this? Have you ever done that
before? No, I haven't.
We're integrating your brothers. This
one societies now you know how to use
the well. Excellent. Thank you so much.
Very valuable. How to say honorable gift
that we can give. Yeah. Really? So yeah
in we should we should do it like this
ourselves and now from this time you are
also his brother. Thank you. Thank you.
It's like it's like a football ceremony.
It's lovely to meet you my brother. Your
hospitality has been fantastic and look
it's happening outside like an official
building as well. What is building? What
is this building? I I think it's like
previously church and now I don't know
it's for different purposes. Okay.
Well, this this ceremony
lighthouse mentoring, which is a unique
and vital initiative within the Sapiens
Institute, mentors those struggling with
doubts, empowers new Muslims, guides
those who have left the dean, and
provides support to imams, teachers,
parents, and dua to make an impact in
the daer. This Ramadan, we're taking
lighthouse mentoring to the next level
as its own organization. We've already
mentored thousands, achieving an
incredible 90% success rate in helping
people reconnect with Islam and make a
lasting impact in their communities. But
we can't stop there. There are many
people all around the world that need
our help. We need
1,500 lightkeepers, supporters, and
donors who will commit just £10 a month
to ensure this life-changing work
continues. Be the first to take
Lighthouse to the next level. Be a
lightkeeper this Ramadan.